a shoe of fury in Guadalajara against
alleged police brutality the arrest and
death of construction worker Giovanni
Lopez a month ago has caused controversy
and conflicting accounts in Mexico's
second largest city police say the 30
year old was detained for disturbing the
peace but this video shared widely on
social media provoked protests not far
from the city
bystanders identify the man being shoved
into a vehicle as Lopez they say police
were using excessive force and that he
was arrested for not wearing a mask
they're mandatory to prevent the corona
virus spread police say he was taken out
of his self in medical treatment and
died hours later the police deny
brutality but protesters are demanding
accountability while some used batons to
smash police vehicles some police
officers pick up whatever they can to
fend off protesters one policeman had
petrol pulled over him and set on fire
the governor of Jalisco's state says
video of Lopez's arrest doesn't show the
reality the misleading way in which they
made everyone Angeles Co believe that
Giovanni was arrested for not wearing a
mask that's already been exposed by the
public prosecutor and what happened
today was the cherry on the cake it was
the way in which they allowed a
legitimate protest a protest for a cause
to be infiltrated and turned violent the
government minister for Human Rights
accuses the police of using excessive
force saying it's a clear violation of
Human Rights and he's condemning the
events which police use force for
preventative measures protests have
swelled across Mexico in solidarity with
George Floyd's death in the United
States but many Mexicans are also
dealing with their own issues with the
police where they live human rights
groups have collected years of evidence
of police brutality torture
and extrajudicial killings and proptosis
in guadalajara says what happened to
giovanni Lopez is the latest example of
that and they're demanding justice nor
about a manly al Jazeera